hey what's up guys my name is eterno and
welcome to the 12th episode of the
serialization series so I know I said
last time that we would be talking about
reading files right and deserializing
stuff today but i just realized just now
that we're actually missing one piece of
the puzzle as far as our civilization
cows and that is strings right we cannot
set it where we cannot serialize strings
right now I mean sure I guess we could
convert them to bytes and sterilized
that or something and we can I mean
we've got the ability to utilize all
these primitive types like integer short
all that stuff and they're called fields
right we also have a raise which we can
serialize right and then wall that kind
of goes into an object and then that
goes into the database but we can't like
what if we want a field that is a string
how is that going to work right well
glad you asked because that's what this
video is going to be all about now the
way that we're actually going to
implement this is as an array okay
there's two ways you could go about this
you could implement strings as a field
in which case you would have to you know
because you would have that you would
have a name length you'd have a name
you'd have a type in this case you would
have to set the type to string which is
something that you basically like we
don't really want to do that because if
we go into the type into the types here
you can see that really these are all
primitive types and their kind of
supposed to be primitive types because
they're primitive in the sense that if
we look at get size we know the size of
the type all the time right if I was to
have to if I have to add a string here
what would the size of the string be
well that kind of depends on on the
amount of characters in the string right
it depends on the actual string as
string is going to have a string is
going to have a different size depending
on what the string is and you know what
else has different sizes depending on
how big they are arrays right which is
why I raised kind of make more sense you
might want to refer to a field sorry to
a string as a field because when you
think about a string of
like one little object right a string
isn't something that you can it's not
like a rain it's not like you know it's
not really like when you get it back
you're not expecting to get an array of
characters back or anything you're
respecting to get a single object a
string so in that case it kinase like a
field but of course the actual kind of
low level implementation of a string is
just an array of characters which is why
it works so well for this so we're going
to kind of go through this and decide
how it's going to work so first of all
the container type will be set to array
okay the name will be will be fine we'll
even have a name will have a size of
course we'll have a type now the type
this is where this is where this comes
into is where stuff kind of starts
getting real um we could still the type
as a primitive type being one of these
or we could actually set the type of
string again if we did set the type of
string then it wouldn't really be this
is really supposed to be the primitive
type yeah when you think about it and
you're thinking about zero and we and
when you're actually thinking about
serialization in general right you can
only serialize primitive types that is
as far as sterilization goes yeah you
have to write out primitive types that
is how this works okay if you don't for
whatever reason or if I don't know what
will happen right you can't actually
like you there's no way to serialize out
a string because what is a string right
a string is a collection of primitives a
string is a collection of characters
right of chance so that being said we
can't really see relies up a string we
have to serialize out a char array now
however the problem comes from reading
not writing if we wanted to write this
out we could easily do that in fact even
in the current system if i define a
string like and I wanted to serialize
that for some reason and I did I went to
it here but let's just say I do call
something like object at array you can
see if i type in like hello world
something here there is a way to get the
chargeback and really a char sequence
like how do I get I don't know man I
don't really spend too much time with
Java nowadays so I even know how you
surely is a way to get the char to char
array of course so there we go right we
just do that at array of courses has to
be in you or rather an RC array dot char
string name string for example and in
the data being you know that and then
there you have it right we've sterilized
out a string haven't we the issue comes
from reading right when we actually
decide okay hey now i'm going to read in
my string ah how do we know if this is
supposed to be a string or if it
actually just is an array of characters
like should the data be interpreted as
an actual string being like you know
capitalist string right or should i
interpret the data as a char array that
big that that's kind of way we have to
start thinking about it right again we
could even make something called hace
string and then objects contain fields
arrays and strings okay and that's
actually that's actually a plausible
solution i'm actually considering doing
that right now we probably will do that
because the thing is if we did carry
this as an array we would be forced to
do something in this array to let us
know that hey actually this is not
really an array it's more a string right
and if we have to do that then you know
we start getting into kind of you know
do we have an extra bite here that says
is string right or do we maybe change
the type to be a string and that kind of
starts interfering with what an array
actually is because an array should be
an array of primitives and again if you
did want your string to literally be a
char array and specifically you wanted
to have it as an RC array
then you know you can do it this way
like I just said right and that will
work totally fine like if I launch that
right now obviously it's not going to
crash or anything and if I quickly open
up the file here you know you'll see
that hollow world written over here now
one thing I'll note is that obviously
char's are um Chaz are obviously a
16-bit right there are there two bytes
in Java right which is why you have this
kind of extra bite here that's important
though you usually like their this
they're basically called wide strings or
rather white characters because in order
to support more languages and of course
you know all these different symbols
that certain characters carry we need
more than 250 possible characters which
is why a lot of these that that's
basically the reason that this isn't um
that these aren't a single bites right
they have to be they have to be two
bites if you really want supply
everything so you kind of get this but
you still get the idea right this string
gets to realize that is utilized out
like that and everyone is happy that's
why the that's what char is two bytes in
on one line anyway that being said
that's how that works and you can see it
does work so really though if we do want
strangles we're going to have to create
RZ string um for the most part I'm
actually probably just going to steal
this entire class just because i just i
mean i don't need everything let's get
real here let's maybe really get data
size let's just take everything up to
here i'll stop deleting stuff i think
i'll still think it'll be faster
container type string
so we're changing this format a little
bit now because I want to say array
field stringers three objects for
databases five this is potentially like
a format breaking change here luckily we
haven't like release this format or
anything it's a little good its
container will be string will have a
name of course same as always a lot of
size which will have to address later
we'll have a type I know you won't well
we won't have account either we're
really just going to have a bunch of
char data all right we do need the size
there of course let us know how many
characters are in there this size will
actually be a count though now this
assumes the char's again are two bites
okay that that's the way that this
cookie is going to crumble okay we can't
suddenly be like I actually I'm going to
deal with one by Charles no no we have
to buy char's that's it especially
because it's written in Java and Charles
always two bites we should be pretty
safe will make the constructor private I
mean we probably don't need to we
couldn't stand she ate it by just using
a new string i guess but anyway oh we
probably will have size actually we are
kind of having size from everything
right because size isn't the will up
sighs and then we'll have count right i
think that's what we differ rate as well
we had count okay we had size type count
sure we definitely need to have that as
well so we'll set up sighs later as well
update sighs yeah I mean we'd probably
say that how do we rock that I think we
just when we created that we did
something along the lines of updates
size right how we did it so let's steal
maybe the char one because it's the most
appropriate and we'll just place that
here get data size again don't really
care about that if we really wanted to
implement that I mean it would literally
just be that so Chara I will rename to
just data oh I might call this like
characters so he as I'm saying if yep we
wanted to let's also kind of remove all
this if we wanted to return that you
could literally just be characters or
length times the size of the chart get
size that's the kind of the data size
get size again return size update size
would be that sure so that's once we set
it we can kind of update it and then as
far as this goes this needs to return RC
string a sort of RC string dot a new or
something I don't know like I guess you
could call that again as I said this
could just very well be a construct i
guess i'll just create but this could be
done in the constructor in this case no
reason it's not really will create a new
string i'll have a name and then we'll
have the string data i guess okay i'll
call this string so let's see what we
actually need to do so a string dot
count will be the amount of characters i
probably yeah okay so let's do this this
will be dated at length string dot
characters will be data dot to char
array and then we'll call update sighs
and then we return string and that looks
pretty good to me we obviously need some
other things here so for example I think
I we did set name right yeah so we need
to do set name to name
count gets out to data length good
characters again we update size sure so
at this point we need to know the size
so the size should be again the final
byte container type 1 plus true for the
name length right plus whatever the name
is so we work that out here and then
plus the count which is an integer so
it's for I mean again do we really need
that to be an integer probably not what
we could though the size field itself
needs to be included so that's what it
is yeah four billion characters or two
billion characters I should probably be
enough um yeah I mean I want to just say
that enough we could make this a shot if
you wanted to again something that you
should decide for yourself I'm going to
leave it as an int so that we are pretty
happy with all this ok cool so this is
looking pretty good to me I'm just
checking yeah I'm pretty happy with that
alright cool so there we have it this
should be good yes ok cool so um if we
write the bites out now we write out
name length my name and then sighs and
count as what we want to do so we've got
counter enough size and then we actually
write out the characters which course is
just going to be characters ok cool so
that does exist for that cool yeah I
mean that is that is it so in RC object
now I need to store a bunch of strings
so we got filled count will have string
count because I do want to kind of still
treat feels like strings in a way I'll
see string strings or call it strings
when we see realize this stuff out we
will write out will copy this block here
will write out the string count I'll see
string string strings strings get bytes
destination pointer okay cool there we
go so that should work pretty well so
now instead of having to add hello world
will do that only way actually maybe
after though we'll say object is a
matter of course the order here but
anyway we'll say um okay we need the add
string thing as well so let's find add a
field add string RC string string feel
this will be strings and string sighs
bicycle strings like outsize string the
gate size and then finally the string
count of course will get changed to be
strings still sighs all right brilliant
so back here we'll add a string will say
new we can't do that so we'll do our C
string and create example string data
testing our RC string plus okay cool so
we've still got the hello world there
but we also got this if we run this now
and we take a look at I obviously closed
it because I do that all the time let's
quickly take a look at that then what
you should see is of course as I
mentioned if we look at the structure of
RC object we we strings get sterilized
out before arrays right right in the
middle of fields so we should see our
fields expedition y position then we
should see our example string with the
testing our RC string class which is
what we see here again to buy characters
and then we see those arrays okay and if
we look at the string count which we
should see right before the amount of
strength so what the fields are finished
so literally before string
it's actually a little bit difficult to
see it is sometimes better to just have
it on top but we don't okay there are
advantages to both systems this plus is
that y position right so then we have
what we have so that that's the end of
the Y position is that I believe no it's
not yeah it is okay so then we have 0 &
1 which should be our string count right
and then we have I guess the type which
is string which is three ok and then we
have in time of the artsy string class
were right here now we have the name
length which is a short which is no we
don't have that apparently hang on
continue to have a string oh that's that
yeah sorry I thought it was two bites
but it's one bite so then we have the
length of name which is e right which is
14 and then we've got our example string
which is our name and that is 14
characters then we've got the size which
is an integer and then we go to count
which is also an integer which is why it
says here one be right and then we have
the beginning of our thing which ends
here or rather here okay straight after
that I'll sorry string class and here
okay then we have I guess we go back to
yeah there's that short so we go back to
our C object and we have our array count
which is this next short which is one
array that's the container type that's
the length of the name that's the name
that is almost figures the size probable
knows my competence eyes what is it
count or something notice a size three
really do we hang on where we want to be
sized out we don't write the size all
right that's problem
wish right sighs um I guess we should
probably write aside before I write
anything else as well we'll deal with
that later so yeah so we should write
size but we don't so count is 3 which is
a hang on no type sorry is 3 then we
have an integer which has the count is
and then we have a hello world all right
cool so there we go so arrays and
strings are now working yeah size is
something that I feel should get
sterilized out as pretty much the first
thing so you have your container type
and then you probably should have your
size straightaway so if you want to
again skip ahead you don't have to go
through the name length and name to get
to size that could be something but
anyway right now we'll still keep it
like this and I guess right before the
type is once you get sterilized out so
sighs do we actually write that out I
guess we write that out for everything
don't we ask your field for example we
write out the site for that surely ya
know we know we don't maybe I'm not
supposed to write out the size RC feel
doesn't have a size okay because the
type as a size yeah I'll see if you'll
we don't need to do that array though I
would and then finally yeah for string
we are doing that there's no sighs all
right cool so that is it and you can see
a better say as you can see it runs but
clearly add at the size of that actually
adding it so let's go back to our C
array so we have the count which is
there so let's make sure we just go for
class so that we have that we now on it
we should be all successful and
everything should work as expected
alright guys thanks for watching another
episode of sterilization next week or
next episode is probably not going to be
a week from now but next episode we're
going to go on to DC realization okay so
how we can read this data that's in our
file format back into our kind of run
time memory alright thanks for watching
if you enjoyed the video please hit like
button and I'll see you guys next time
goodbye